[Music]
despite having its own unique
interpretation of the web-slinger's
established world insomniac spider-man
is deeply entrenched in Marvel's
expansive lore the game makes reference
to several characters and entities from
the comics and movies with so many
clever details to notice and discover in
spider-man's bustling world we've
highlighted seven of the most
fascinating Easter eggs and Marvel
references so far be wary there are some
minor spoilers ahead
there's a ton of landmarks that it's on
the X take of Manhattan some are real
like Madison Square Garden and the
Empire State Building but others not so
much after all this isn't our Manhattan
it's Marvel's version of the famous
real-life borough as one of Marvel's
central superhero and supervillain hubs
there are a ton of iconic locations
packed in that Marvel fans will
recognize the first major one that folks
will notice is likely the Avengers Tower
located in the Upper East Side district
but there's so much more scattered
around you can find the Wakanda Embassy
in the Midtown district dr. Strange's
home the sanctum sanctorum is located
exactly where it should be in Greenwich
Village and there's even some deeper
like the bar with no name which is a
hidden speakeasy where supervillains can
drink and relax in peace spider-man is
littered with Marvel landmarks we're
only scratching the surface here so we
highly encourage you to explore and see
the rest for yourself
[Music]
one of the side missions has you helping
out a fella named Philip Chang an ESU
student who wants you to find his
missing classmates he's a resourceful
guy having developed advanced facial
recognition technology that allows him
to track down people via their social
media feeds okay maybe that sounds a bit
creepy but it did help Spidey save the
day anyway Philip Chang is a character
from the comics Peter actually attended
university with Chang and they were even
lab mates for a time of course there's
some more complicated history
surrounding him and an evil gang called
the Dragonlords but I will spare you the
complicated details for now
[Music]
after losing their support from the
grant committee and having all their
resources revoked from them by Norman
Osborn otto calls in some favors takes
on a few grants in order to fund his
research one of the funding partners
should be instantly recognizable to
marvel fans we examine some of the new
equipment in the lab you'll discover
paperwork detailing a grant from aim aka
advanced idea mechanics Peter remarks
that their reputation is a tad shady
which is a bit of an understatement for
talking about the very same organization
with the comics aim is a privately
funded organization of terrorists arms
dealers and scientists whose sole
mission is to overthrow the governments
of the world through the use of
technology and scientific advancement so
yeah pretty Shady
[Music]
about halfway through the game you'll
run into a shadowy figure who challenges
you to complete some difficult tasks
around the map this menacing foe is none
other than taskmaster a super villain
who battles spider-man every once in a
while in the comics as you complete
tasks masters challenges you'll start to
learn that he has what's called
photographic reflexes which allows him
to duplicate almost any physical
activity he sees by simply seeing it
performed once it's literally the reason
why he set up these challenges
throughout Manhattan he wants to take
you down by learning your every move
what a creep you sound like you want to
kill me I have so much more to learn in
the side mission internet-famous you get
wrapped up in an Internet challenge that
takes a turn for the worse
after scanning a QR code you're forced
to complete combat and puzzle trials
under a strict time limit in order to
reveal the location of a kidnapping
victim the individual forcing you to do
all this is a social media personality
known as screwball screwball definitely
has some screws loose that's for sure
her whole shtick is the same in the
comics committing crimes while a camera
crew films her and then uploading the
footage on YouTube to earn money it's
worth noting that screwball was first
introduced in 2008 right around the
early years of YouTube but her antics
are more relevant now than ever before
[Music]
during the latter half of the game
spider-man needs to make a quick save in
order to stop a speeding subway train
his first attempt should be a familiar
one to spider-man fans as it's the same
method that was used to stop a subway
train from spider-man
2 the game makes it very clear nod to
this even going as far as the halving
spider-man say it totally worked last
time when it inevitably fails nice one
in Zambia we see what you're doing the
backpacks are more than just mindless
collectables you grab to upgrade
spider-man's abilities they each
represent and form a little bit about
Peter Parker's life and history as a
superhero for example you can find his
original mark 1 web shoes but there's a
lot of other fascinating references and
tidbits in between like this business
card for Daredevils law practice and
these vials containing the blood of the
lizard and the sand of uh.well Sandman
the backpack collectables are rich with
narrative details that reference both
spider-man and Marvel history so don't
hesitate to grab them in your travels
you never know what cool stuff you might
learn were there any spider-man or
Marvel Easter eggs you discovered that
you don't see here feel free to let us
know about them in the comments below
and make sure to check out our
spider-man review and our tips video
detailing all the things you need to
know to be the best spider-man
[Music]
you